[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is done cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsay show we help people
build wealth do work that they really
love and create actual amazing
relationships it's a show about your
life and your money we're glad you're
here george campbell ramsey personality
host of entree leadership and the fine
print podcasts on the ramsey network is
my co-host today open phones here as we
talk about your life and your money the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five
five two two
five
triple eight eight two five five
two two
five mike is with us mike is in irvine
california to start off this hour hey
mike how are you
good morning dave good morning uh
george pleasure to speak with you both
it's an honor you too how can we help
sir
um so i just had a question i've been on
baby step four five and six for a few
years now while trying to passively save
up for a down payment i'm 34 years old
and i've already managed to save in uh
for retirement about eighty thousand
dollars in my roth 401k
however since i've lived in southern
california with rising interest rates
and a home appreciation the market i
feel is kind of outpacing the rate at
which i can passively save for the down
payment on the side while investing so
i'm thinking about stepping back to baby
step 3b so that i can really turn on the
fire so that i can meet this goal cool
what do you make uh i make about 120 000
a year okay cool how much you got saved
so far for your house
about 30. okay how long you been working
on it
uh
after i got my emergency fund saved up
about
one and a half years
so i can basically without accounting
for any windfalls i can put about twenty
thousand dollars or i guess that's
that's if i stop saving
uh or stop investing i've got about
thirty thousand how long how long to
build the 30 000 is what i was asking
oh five years
oh wow forever
yeah when you said passive you meant it
okay yeah
in order to invest about 15 percent of
my income uh
i basically don't have a lot of income
left over to
so you're you're you know you're in a as
you said a high price real estate market
so you are the situation where i would
just pull back into a 3b temporarily
stop your baby step 4 and just pile
money up for your down payment and then
you could considerably increase it i
mean that would have 20 25 000 a year to
the program
yeah so basically if i if i step back to
3b i'd be able to save about twenty
thousand dollars a year meaning about
five years i'd have an additional
hundred thousand to put towards the no
that's not true you would save a lot
more than that because that you're
putting that much in at fifteen percent
of your income
uh thirty thirty thousand took five
years
no honey fifteen percent of a hundred
and twenty is more than 25 000
and you're already putting money in
so your entire 15
is going to be
what almost 20 000 bucks okay plus
whatever you've been doing so you should
be putting in you should be putting in
30 000 bucks
sure okay cool so are you investing 15
of your gross income currently
i have been yes that's that that's how i
was able to save up the 80 000 in my raw
yeah i mean that would equal to 18 000
extra you have to pile on i want that
done in fact way faster than five years
do you have a goal for the down payment
currently
my goal is about anywhere from 100 to
150. okay and then how much is the house
going to be in your area
uh probably around five six
condos have gone up in price in the over
the last couple years so they're
starting a re they're they're kind of
equaling for a two bedroom condo about
six and a half
okay cause that still means you'd have
about a half million mortgage so i would
still crunch the numbers and make sure
that this is gonna be around a quarter
of your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
and that will help dictate the down
payment bottom line is yeah i would do
what you're suggesting let's pull back
to the 3b
so with that i kind of had a follow-up
question with stepping back to 3b and
trying to figure out the best place to
hold this cache in order to
save it i know i've watched previous
videos of yours on the subject and i
know that you recommend
mutual funds or an s p index fund with
the goal of netting around 10 to 12
percent
um that would not be that would not be
for a three-year investment or four-year
investment that's for some for long term
okay it's going to be a high yield
savings account money market account not
going to be gaining a lot of interest
correct
now but the question the question i know
i know what i'm about to ask might be a
little taboo but i think the goal of
what i'm trying to ask is
my my employer offers the 401k with a 25
match and i discovered that i can take a
hardship withdrawal which will allow me
to withdraw that money for the purchase
of a primary residence where i would pay
a 10 penalty on the early withdrawal and
in taxes on the matches are any taxes on
the match or the gains but if i
deposited let's just say one hundred
thousand dollars of my post tax money i
could then withdraw that one hundred
thousand dollars take the ten penalty
and i would still be at a net profit of
a 15 match
regardless of the time if i did it in
three years if i did it in five years if
i did it in 10 years i would that would
still what if i withdrew what i
deposited
i would pay 10 on what i deposited and
net a fifteen percent you know i know
number one number one buying a house is
not a hardship
so i don't i don't think you qualify for
a hardship withdrawal
i i've talked to my my uh 401k provider
the purchase of a primary residence does
fall under hardship withdrawal wow
what a provider
okay um
well the answer is still you're right
it's taboo and the reason it's taboo is
when you start monkeying around with
your future retirement plan in order to
buy a house you've stepped over the line
into desperate and anytime i get
desperate i generally get stupid
um and i've done it a bunch of my life i
i try not to get desperate for that
reason because i right after that stupid
and right after my stupid is a lot less
money so you've calculated all this out
to where you have a net net net positive
effect what you left out was the fact
that you neutered your retirement plan
while you were doing it
and you just you just stripped it all
away and so no we're going to leave your
retirement plan alone and
here's the other thing you have left out
of your entire set of assumptions an
increase in income in the next three to
five years which you should have
because you're one of the people that
stayed in california
and so while roughly a million people
left california and new york in the last
14 months
and so
we don't know exactly what that's going
to do to real estate prices long term
i'm not predicting a california crash
but i am predicting a shortage of labor
particularly skilled labor at your level
because guess who left california it
weren't broke people baby it was the
people that were producing and didn't
want to pay the taxes and didn't want to
live in that
woke environment and so where they've
lost their minds and so that's what
you're left with and and so you really
are you've become a really good
commodity you and of yourself for
staying there it's a great place to work
because there's a shortage of your type
of labor and so i think your income's
going to go up dramatically that's what
i was thinking the the part of the
equation we can control here is our
income and that might mean a side job
for now i don't know what that looks
like if it's worth switching careers i
mean it seems like he's happy where he's
at but if you can make 150 that changes
the numbers on this down payment
situation the other thing mike is um you
have to be careful and you're very good
at analyzing these things you have good
critical thinking skills everything you
displayed in the conversation was
actually logical
you did a good job of laying it out and
presenting it which is hard to do when
you're on the radio it's kind of nerve
wracking so you did a real good job but
that tells me you're a detail guy and be
careful to not get um so far in that
down in the details that you miss common
sense
and um and in the analytics that you
miss common sense you need to do both
and you've done a good job with it i'm
complimenting you on that but common
sense says don't use your retirement for
your house purchase
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
open phones this hour george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
the phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five two two five how
many times have you found yourself
saying one day when you're thinking
about a goal you have one day i'll buy a
house one day i'll have a happy career
one day i won't have to battle with
anxiety anymore stop waiting around with
your one day and start right now this is
why we created smart conference smart
conference is a one day oddly enough
event where we tackle all of your areas
of your life guys let's face it we could
all use that kind of boost right now you
hear from the nation's top thought
leaders on money
career mental health relationships
marriage leadership this event hitting
the road will be in dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd event passes are
selling fast best-selling authors and
world-class speakers
will be on each of the subjects rachel
cruz dr john deloney ken coleman george
campbell christina ellis craig and amy
groschel speaking on marriage from life
church and we'll be talking about career
we'll be talking about leadership we'll
be talking about money uh we'll be
talking about mental health we're gonna
be dealing with everything and when you
leave you will be smarter it's october
22nd event passes are selling fast the
vip and platinum are already gone but
you can still get general admissions for
39 bucks they're available right now at
ramseysolutions.com so get your event
passes today our question today comes
from blinds.com
satisfaction guaranteed they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you miss measure you pick the wrong
color you screw up it's a you screwed up
guarantee they'll remake your blinds for
free free samples free shipping the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more always check these guys out
they are absolutely amazing
blinds.com today's question comes from
rashad in washington dc
i was wondering if there is a baby step
8 that could help listeners reach a
level of wealth in the tens of millions
and leave a legacy that can benefit our
children and grandchildren and promote
amazing generosity
well good news for a shot it exists and
it's the baby step right before it baby
step seven build wealth and give and
that can look different for a lot of
people some people that could be a
million for you i hope it's tens of
millions and i hope you leave a legacy
and you give outrageously generous and
you leave an inheritance to your
children's children as proverbs says so
absolutely dave this can be done and
it's some of the most inspiring parts of
this whole plan
well here's what happens
the first
five to 10 million
of net worth that someone uh gets which
by the way if you have a 10 million
dollar net worth and it's producing 10
percent
that's a million dollars of your income
okay you can change your family tree and
be outrageously generous and impact your
entire community with a million dollars
a year okay
so you can get there for sure all right
the uh but but you know investing in
your 401k your home maybe a couple of
rental properties uh that's what the
typical person does in our studies of
actual millionaires in that first five
to ten million
to go from
10 million to say a hundred mate
uh which you would start to look then at
uh billionaires as an example which
would be um
you know ten times a hundred million or
uh what is it 1 000 million
is a billion is that right yes um that's
a lot of difference okay so all of your
forbes 400 for instance are billionaires
none of them became billionaires with
their 401k
or paying off their home
none of them okay they didn't become
billionaires doing that uh they in in
virtually every case owned or operated
or took public a large company
in virtually every case oprah
walmart family chick-fil-a family
you know you go down the list and uh
dell
gates
of course warren buffett but in every
case they had an idea and i know a guy
who's worth several billion um
and he makes parts for cell phones
you know but he just they but they grew
the company hugo
and took it public or didn't and made
the cash flow off of it or sold the
company
generally to go from the 10 15 million
up into the stratosphere so to speak you
truly are a one percenter then
okay
um and i mean you're a tenth of a
percenter then but it's generally you
take some of the money that you have
made and
some of it somehow grows exponentially
uh and so
you know in our case uh my net worth is
considerably more than 10 million and so
uh i mean the building we're sitting in
is uh
you know the building complex here is
worth a couple hundred million and it's
all paid for so just to give you an idea
so that's you know but did we get there
with our 401k no no i mean i've sold 25
million books i own a huge business that
makes a lot of money and helps a lot of
people and so that's that's what ends up
happening to get into that stratosphere
but the point is this the thing he's
trying to do is create a generosity
movement and if you'll start where you
are
with generosity today
and every time you make more increase
your generosity you're going to see your
opportunities increase as well and your
opportunities for i mean i remember the
first time i made ten thousand dollars
and my tithe check was a thousand
dollars
man i thought i was the most spiritual
dude on the planet i just gave a
thousand dollars me and god i'm helping
god out here to which god is laughing at
my little thousand dollar gift right you
thought he'd get an extra fuel on the
ground he's like look at that grain of
sand he thinks he's something
you know but i thought i mean i really
was proud of myself i just gave a
thousand dollars away man to the church
i am a spiritual dude giving feels good
but it does it does feel good but i was
pretty arrogant about it what i'm saying
i'm being i'm being a little too
authentic here but i really did i felt
really i mean but the first time you do
and that but the thing is get used to
doing that then get the rhythm of that
the more money you make the more money
you give the more money you make the
more money you give and constantly be
doing that and you will find yourself
starting to impact entire sectors around
you and change your family tree but ten
million dollars change your family tree
oh yeah you don't have to have on what
i'm hearing is don't wait until you go
well when i have this much money then
i'll start giving give today with what
you got because you can ramp it up over
time because it's a muscle you need to
build in a rhythm because my point is
the first time i gave 100 i thought it
was a lot then the first time i gave a
thousand dollars and then we had uh what
year before last we gave a million in
one day oh that's right remember that
that was fun around christmas time yeah
it was a blast we had so much fun doing
that so that was trippy you know and
then i thought i kind of thought kind of
the same thing like i just gave away a
million dollars but it wasn't even my
money it was god's money so then i had
to get over myself you know so that kind
of stuff but it's just it's a process
you know
and but the muscle built gradually over
time i didn't go from i don't give
anything to a million in one day
and so you just you build it over time
that's a beautiful question what a
beautiful spirit i love that
thanks excellent stuff jerry's in new
york hey jerry welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dude how are you all doing today
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
yeah so uh i'm curious what your
opinions are on moving and taking a pay
cut for a partner
so uh low context my girlfriend of about
a year and a half just finished her
master's program in education and now
she wants to teach english in europe for
a while before officially starting her
career in the states
and she wants me to join her and my job
will let me go they'll help with visas
and everything but
um the pay is location base so i'd be
dropping from about 125k in new york to
about 75k in europe you love this and
also
i do
how long you've been dating
50k about a year and a half a year and a
half this is a serious dead gun
relationship 50 000
yeah
and uh so i'm also about like two years
into my mortgage on my apartment here
and i wasn't really planning on leaving
until i met her um so like now i'm like
ready to lay route to new york kind of
but she's done with it because it's way
too expensive for teachers in new york
um and she's not sure if she wants to
live in new york when she comes back to
the states so it kind of feels like this
decision ultimatum do i sacrifice like
my life my income and everything oh i
don't like the word ultimatum where
there's 50 000 worth of love involved
is that how it was presented to you
either you move or this is over
she definitely like is done with the
city and like ready for like another
place to live and we do like traveling
together so
this might be more into her than she is
into you
[Music]
i said you're more into her than she is
into you
i i don't think she's skunk she's gonna
ditch new york and you with it you're
gonna ditch new york to follow her i
don't know man i'm just oh man i ain't
dated in years i don't know how to tell
you what to do with this um you gotta
decide how much this is gonna work i if
you were my uh little brother or my
nephew or something i would tell you
don't go unless you're married i agree
and i would say with caution then it's
worth a sacrifice now this is a bet for
life it's not a bet for a weekend
fleeing in europe what if she's not
giving up everything yeah
hope you can match up to that whoa
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one
dashboard go to netsuite.com ramsey
right now to get their free white paper
jump start your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today bill is on the line bill
is in oregon hey bill welcome to the
ramsey show
thank you it's good to be here good to
have you sir i see on my screen you're
debt-free congratulations how much did
you pay off
a hundred and
eighty nine thousand dollars all right
how long did this take you
uh about ten years altogether
okay and your range of income then
during that ten years
i went from sixty thousand um and then
social security kicked in
um along with some raises and i was up
to a hundred and twelve thousand right
now i'm up to a hundred and twelve
thousand social security kicked in how
old are you
uh i'm 70. ah cool okay what kind of
debt was the 189
uh house and car mostly with with some
miscellaneous things thrown in there
okay so at 60 years old or so something
rings the bell and you go i got to get
this mess cleaned up tell me your ramsay
story how did you get to connect to the
ramsey way
well um about 12 years ago
i listened to financial peace university
and it made a lot of sense
and so i went about
and
there were a lot of financial issues at
the time a divorce
um
and uh i lost
half my retirement
and i had
three kids to raise uh on my own
uh
so
there were a lot of uh
financial issues at the time
and it just made sense
to
uh get out of as much debt as i possibly
could
i think the biggest mistake that i made
other than taking on my retirement to to
help raise the kids um
the biggest mistake i made was was not
developing and maintaining an emergency
fund
so the divorce happened a lot longer
than 12 years ago
yeah i think it happened i think it's
about 17 years ago okay all right and so
you were in your 50s at that point
right and the kids were how old
uh 14 12 and 10. wow
okay cool
yeah so they're always so they're all
grown now they're they're all grown and
hopefully off the payroll now right hey
they're they're grown they're wonderful
human beings
all college graduates all
self-sufficient and uh all
follow your principles as well
wow you did a good job well done bill
thank you bill i'm curious because for a
lot of people they feel like it's too
late for them and i love your story
because here you are you know at 70
totally debt-free house and everything
what do you say to that person who might
be in their 50s and their 60s going well
i've made too many money mistakes i got
too much baggage i can't clean this up
now
i i don't think it's ever too late to
clean it up um i think that that when i
i decided when i decided to kick in full
gear and say i've got to have that
emergency fund that's that's critical
um
that that i would say to those people
it's never too late just start following
the steps and you know even the the baby
step one of of a thousand dollars
in in your emergency fund
you know it's a huge step
uh and you feel good about it and you
start feeling good about your finances
instead of
uh it always being a negative point
yeah there's something about that
confidence that sense of i did something
i'm in control for the first time that
moves the needle on everything else
doesn't it
right right and and my my budget in the
past was
essentially my paycheck
yeah so
spend until it's gone
okay so you're 70 years old 189 000 paid
off you're 100 debt-free house and
everything
right how's that feel
it feels wonderful it feels fantastic i
paid it off in june and i'm i'm still
on a little bit of a high
i love it so bill did you have a vision
for what i want retirement to look like
and obviously you're still working and
you're still healthy which is awesome
but did you have that vision in your
mind of here's why i'm doing this i want
to retire with dignity
i i think that that
that was part of it i also had
my significant other came into my life
and she uh
essentially said
you're going to this seminar
and you need to get something
straightened up uh or or uh wow i'm
getting i'm hitting the road
what seminar was it
uh
financial peace university oh that's
awesome so she got you on board
right right and and
where they had both feet in instead of
just one wow so behind every great man
is a woman forcing them to go to
financial peace university there you go
there it is
exactly i love it way to go bill we're
proud of you man thank you what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
i think it's uh
following following the financial peace
university principles uh and and just
being disciplined um and and i think
that that
you start
uh
having um
you start enjoying
following those principles because it
really they really work and you and you
you start realizing what hey
i'm actually i don't i don't know
on my car anymore oh wow i you know i
don't know on this loan anymore oh wow
i've paid this off that's great um i
think one of the biggest joys is is as
soon as i got a substantial
um
oh i'm having a brain cramp uh a
substantial uh
uh
fund
no um
an emergency fund i'm sorry thank you
david uh
uh as soon as i got a substantial
emergency fund going a hot water heater
and
a dishwasher went out of course and i
went down and bought them
in cash and
you know
i felt good about it it was it was like
oh yeah i could do this
turns an emergency into an inconvenience
well done sir that's pretty good about
it so anyway well done we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too i'm proud of you
you went and did it man you left the
cave killed something in drug at home uh
we're gonna send you a one-year
membership to financial peace university
you've been through it you know what it
does maybe you know somebody that needs
to go through it you can give it to them
and also the same thing with the book
the total money makeover i'm gonna send
you one of those as well so way to go
bill in oregon 189 000 paid off in 10
years making 60 to 112. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
one
two oh i got to take away from hold on
one two three i am dead free
[Applause]
that's how that's done
don't tell me it's too late never too
late don't tell me it's too late i'll
just show you bill if you can fog a
mirror it's not too late that's it well
done sir very well done excellent
excellent job
all right laurel is with us laurel is in
chicago hey laurel welcome to the ramsay
show hey
hey jay thank you so much for taking my
call and that person caller and actually
i'm brand new to all this ramsey stuff
sorry to call us guf
we are having our first baby september
4th and
i got a little bit triggered and
realized we really need to get serious
about our finances i have never felt
like we're behind but i definitely don't
feel like we're ahead so my question is
for someone in our position where we are
embarking on a huge life shift and
simultaneously wanting to change how we
manage our money what's the quickest way
to save with the arrival of the baby and
boost our income nothing like a baby to
give you a wake-up call
oh my gosh yes this got real this just
got real are you saying like 20 days
from now oh my gosh you know yeah baby
any minute it's like 20 days from now
oh yeah you guys seriously it's so scary
how much do you have saved currently
okay so we have 3 500 in cash we have 12
grand in the savings accounts um and
then we have about like 40
000 in investments and precious metals
cool
all right how much in precious metals
18 18 000.
all right do you really want to know
what i would do today
i do i really do
i don't know if you're going to do it
i'd cash out the precious metals today
i'd put the cash in a savings account i
would pay minimum payments on all your
debt and don't do anything fancy and see
how big a pile of cash you can have
between now and september 3rd and then
start working the baby steps
okay and i'm going to send you a
one-year membership to financial peace
university you can start after you get
home with baby you and your husband can
go through that you're about to change
this kid's family tree
because you're a good mom
i'm proud of you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phone is a triple eight eight two
five five two two five
rich is with us in chicago hi rich
welcome to the ramsey show
hi george and dave thanks for having me
on um
i have a quick question about
allocating funds into a 529 plan
my wife and i are just coming up here at
the end of baby step three
and looking into four five and six uh
we're a little older
my children are
sophomore in high school freshman in
high school and then sixth grade
and curious as to
how to best invest in our 529 plans
going forward
they do have a current investment
balance um but i just curious which i
invest all my money now into the older
what's the uh
what's the current balance
uh around 125 000 total among all three
okay so they got like 40 grand each all
right and um
what's your household income
uh around 220 that's good news okay cool
all right so i'm looking to invest about
2500 a month
and i'm not sure if it should all go
into one count if i should split it
among the three or what's the best way
to think about this
doesn't matter much um
because the
529 can be transferred to a sibling
anyway
so if you don't use it yeah so if you
don't use it
uh you like you dump it all in the
oldest one and you don't use it you can
roll it down to the next one and so on
if you wanted to
um
so here's the thing 30 000
you're not going to have enough in these
accounts to pay for the kids colleges
you're going to be cash flowing some of
it
understood with 30 000 a year for six
years
right i mean we know that that's going
to be
part of it but at the same time we don't
want to have to sacrifice our retirement
no i didn't want you to i want you to
put 15 percent of your income into
retirement
and
so here's my point okay we've got to
have other things in this equation other
than just saving for 529 to get your
kids to college
number one
uh college choice
is the most important part of the
equation
on whether you can afford to go to
college or not
because you can send them to an in-state
school for ten to twelve thousand
dollars average annual tuition across
america or you can send them to a
private average annual for twenty five
thousand
you can't afford twenty five thousand
times three you're not gonna have that
much money
your kids aren't going to private
schools
unless they're scholarships or something
like
that
there you go see now we're thinking i
got you okay you're moving or unless
they get really great jobs or but more
than anything is scholarships
okay and so they need to start working
on scholarships and now the sixth grader
does
and not actually not actually ordering
them but thinking about them because
here's what christina ellis would tell
you she's going to tell you that that
you know the sophomore is pretty late in
the game but the rest of them uh grades
matter
and now grades equal money
is what this amounts to so you know you
getting a good grade is just not making
daddy proud this is about whether you
have money to go to school so you need
to get your little butt in the books
let's go game on buddy game on here we
go number one number two plan on working
number three plan on going to a school
that is affordable and start
indoctrinating the kiddos right now with
all of those three things scholarships
school choice work
and then you do all you can which is 30
000 bucks a year right now
and
and you can do 30 000 bucks cash flow
and cash flow state school on the last
kid
uh you know that'll get them into the la
that'll run the last one through uh just
like without having saved anything and
so
um i don't care which of the 529s you're
dumping in with that in mind do you have
you had a conversation with any of the
kids rich especially the older ones
about what college looks like
uh yeah you know going through the
process um
i'm actually an fpu coordinator right
now so we make them watch the videos the
week before i teach the class with us
um and we've watched the documentary on
borrow features oh you're dead i was
going to send you a link to well-versed
on everything well that should startle
them enough to have the right
conversations and go debt how are we
going to pay for this we got to have a
plan i want to go to school debt free
and that is the number one factor
because when debt is off the table
they're gonna get creative and they're
you're gonna go here's what i can do
here's what you need to do yeah you're
way ahead of the game with all that
because what i was afraid of when i was
talking to you until you told me all
that i told or told george all that was
uh you're making really good money so
you're running around with people and
your kids are running around with people
whose kids are going to very expensive
schools
correct yeah and so uh well my my
daughter's going to northwestern well
you're my kid
sorry and so uh i mean that's what our
kid that's what our kids heard
you're going to a state school oh my
you're never going to be successful and
all three of my kids make more than that
snotty person who said that so um but
you know that's the thing you know that
that's the thing you run into because
the group you run around with affects
this bad i mean if you come out of a
blue-collar working neighborhood just
getting into college is awesome that's
where i came from right and i just the
fact that i got in was it surprised
everybody you know much less could pay
for it and so the uh it was because it
wasn't norm but the norm is the hotty
toddy you know
your environment your parenting it
shapes a lot of that
you're doing a great job when your kids
hate
i want to get as far away from mom and
dad as possible so i'm going to go all
the way across the country to a private
but listen what he did he got him to
watch the class on in financial peace on
here's how the college dollars work then
he watched the documentary borrowed
future he's an fba coordinator so he's
talking to him about the how what wise
education choices look like and he's
planning a 529. this guy's a genius he's
done it all you're saying you're the
total package rich and you're rich so
you got it made you're rich why do you
even need this you're rich he's they're
gonna be you are the personification
well done man very well done i love it
yeah so yeah
i would throw it
uh let me think just to answer your
question specifically given now that now
that we know you did everything right
already i where would i put that i would
put it in the i would put it all in the
youngest and i would cash flow the
oldest
because the youngest is going to grow
more
it's going to have more he's got more
time to grow the money and the growth is
tax-free in the roth and you don't have
that benefit from a sophomore the amount
that mutual fund is going to grow in two
years is not squat it's negligible i
mean you put 30 000 bucks in there it's
gonna grow six thousand dollars or
something it's not gonna be in two or
three years so you're not going to get
enough growth that the fact that it's in
a uh 529 growing tax free matters
mathematically so i'm going to probably
throw the majority of it towards the kit
youngest kid
actually i'm probably going to put a
little in all of them i'm probably going
to go like 25 500 or something 20 000 a
little one five five and the other two
older ones but everybody gets the
indoctrination
where you go to school there is no
single piece of research that correlates
credibly
where you go to school with whether or
not you're successful
not a single piece of research none as a
matter of fact wall street journal did a
survey
detailed in-depth survey
78
of the top 500 companies traded on the
stock markets
ceos
went to state schools
eight out of ten
just take that harvard and princeton
now figure it out mit
okay they're famous schools but they do
not produce
results commensurate with their expense
now if you can go to vanderbilt or
harvard or
uh mit you're not mad
i'm not yale here or if you want to go
there and you can go there with
scholarships free ride and you want to
go there sure i'm not mad at you i mean
presidents went to harvard that's it's
cool go that's fine uh president really
wasn't on my future plans uh nor is it
still so um you know but but here's the
thing and i wasn't planning on being an
attorney either so harvard law right uh
so that none of that but i know lots of
attorneys that make a million dollars a
year that did not go to a school that
you've ever heard of
the point is success is not determined
by that yeah lots of people go to state
schools and they have great jobs great
careers can get great experience and
very few people have asked me where i
went to school dave it's a little upset
not that i went to any impressive where
did you go to school it's complicated
and now now we can ask now we can ask
the question university of mobile dave
you did that's right i finished school
there i went to star wars
staff that's right but you weren't you
weren't a singer
no no i stayed out of that i wanted a
real job after school dave so i wanna i
got a communications degree like rachel
there you go so i'm up there with the
greats hey it worked out i'm
communicating and you were just on fox a
minute ago that's right right before we
went on air take that
using my communications degree there you
go you used it you're using your degree
george right now that's pretty strange
look at that and i never asked you where
and no one knows that school
i knew it i know it's fantastic i didn't
know it for i knew it for the singers
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
so
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show debt is
dumb cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five
two two
five
jessica is starting off this hour in
oklahoma city hi jessica how are you
hey i'm doing okay how about you thank
you so much for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm currently 31 my husband is 44 and
has recently been diagnosed with heart
failure
and
he has lost his jaw he has been approved
for social security but we do not have
any term life for him and i have tried
all throughout
no one says he's
approvable
for term life and i know that you guys
are against whole life but i'm just kind
of
scared and need to if he's not
approvable for term life he's not
approvable for whole life
so it's just i don't have any options
except you just kind of whole life
doesn't wave medical just because
they're rip off
right that doesn't that didn't work that
way
um
wow
so what type of heart failure how old is
he
he's 44.
um he has he has 10 heart function
so he's in line for what a uh uh a
transplant right is he in line for a
transplant
he's uh
the cardiologists are thinking that
he'll be on the list within the year
yeah
my goodness
i'm so sorry you guys gotta be scared
out of your minds
yeah with our two-year-old yeah we're
we're very scared oh baby girl
how's his health wise uh as far as his
ability to work
he's not i mean he he can't no you
better
yeah he's a lot of household chores get
him out of breath easily i mean
it's just kind of been yeah they do me
too but it's for a different reason
yeah i know
oh my gosh
i'm so sorry kiddo uh so uh let me think
here
you got a two-year-old
yes and what do you make i have
i make uh 44.
thousand a year and he's applied for ssi
when
he applied for ssi in april and he
became it was approved for uh in july
and he receives it this month for i
think like 1200 per month yeah does he
have any student loan debt
he does not all the debt is on me okay
and how much debt do you have
71 000 okay
and some of it's on student loans
53 000 of it is yes okay
all right what's the rest
the rest is uh medical bills and um
mostly just uh medical bills on my end
yeah
all right
um
okay no baby steps
you're in survival mode right now
financially speaking
okay okay i want to pay minimum payments
on everything and i want to pile up cash
as high as i can pile it for a while
now that may be a year
but for right now you're in the middle
of a crisis the tornado has hit or is
coming at you or whatever we want to
call it okay the
hurricane is off offshore and they're
saying it's coming to your town whatever
metaphor we want to use here okay
so i'm going to batten up the hatches
we're going to board up the windows and
we're going to just pile up cash
because if you had even if you had the
71 thousand dollars in debt if you had
50 000 in cash in the bank right now you
feel different wouldn't you exactly yeah
and you're not going to have 50 000
anytime soon but i'm just saying that's
the point of that
suggestion is to get you guys some peace
until we get to some resolution on his
health
and the resolution is going to be a
transplant probably
probably i'm not i'm not medical but i
mean 10 function it's kind of a common
sense thing at that point
so um
i mean i'm just that that's the hope
that's the good news wouldn't it be
yeah it would be yeah
and and so uh
do you guys have any money right now in
savings
no
or 500 okay okay all right the only kind
of insurance that he is eligible for to
go back to your original question
now that we know the source of it
is what's called uh no
is where there's no medical requirement
no medical exam okay
this type of insurance is anywhere from
five to 20 times more expensive
do you have a mortgage
no
you're renting
renting correct okay all right
if you had a mortgage going and getting
a mortgage insurance policy is a
non-medical it's it's five six times
more expensive than regular term but you
could call your mortgage company today
and that would pay off your mortgage so
that's not an option for you but for
other people listening facing the same
thing let's bring that up okay the other
types of automatic issue guaranteed
issue policies are non-medical are
usually low amounts and per thousand
they're expensive but it would be like
call your bank and see if they have a
ten thousand dollar policy that's an
auto issue
okay and then find you know find five or
six of those things
and have them around
and it's not enough and it's not proper
financial planning but it's what's
available to you today giving given
these limitations and you don't have a
lot of money to spend
on the insurance policy even if you
could get one
but uh but you've been you've been told
correctly he's not insurable
i don't think he's going to get a life
insurance policy
because life insurance policies are
issued
based on the you know the statistical
evidence of the situation and they're
not going to in this situation they
don't issue it's very difficult for
instance if you have a bad case of
diabetes to get life insurance uh if you
have you know if you're just came off a
chemo you know it's hard to get life
insurance or if you're in chemo it's
impossible to get life insurance that
kind of stuff so
um
that that's the type of thing you're
facing because they're just looking
they're they're
uh just running statistical averages
is what they're all is their whole game
so um
so i think you can get a few of these
guaranteed issue policies uh see if you
have any kind of thing through your work
that has a group plan
that you can add a guaranteed issue on
that
a lot of those are uh you can buy spouse
and if you can buy it on your spouse
through your work and you can get it
might be twenty five thousand bucks it
might be fifty thousand bucks it's not
going to be five hundred
right
okay
but again you can pick that up and so
the the word guaranteed issue or no
medical is what you're looking for and
that's code for
expensive per thousand but generally a
small number of thousands
so it's not total so the real dollars
are not a lot but the coverage isn't a
lot either
you follow me
yes i do that's the type of thing you
can kind of piece that together in a
patchwork quilt and get you some
coverage if you work really hard at this
you might pull together a hundred
thousand dollars worth or something
which is still not enough if you got a
two-year-old
right yeah but it's more than you got
today
and in the meantime i just want you guys
to be in cash preservation mode
no
uh
no frivolous spending you've not been
doing that you don't have the money to
do that but
no frivolous spending and i'm going to
put you guys into financial peace
university where you're learning to work
together and handle money together
because that's going to be critical with
all the things you have facing you in
the next three years
so hang on uh we'll pick up also get you
signed up for that as our gift and let
us know how you're doing kiddo
we're scared with you we understand
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
thanks for joining us america if you're
listening to this show there's a good
chance you finally had enough
where you are right now in life
enough mediocre relationships enough
being stuck in a meaningless 9 to 5 job
enough struggling to pay for gas well
that's everybody enough paying for
groceries the tough truth is there's
nothing going to change until you decide
to change it
so this month we're bringing back the
ramsey 10 sale get up to 83 off our
number one best-selling books and tools
that'll help you finally take control of
your life and your money if debt's
eating up your income like a baptist
gobbling up a casserole well check out
the total money makeover or rachel's
book know yourself know your money both
number one best sellers if you want to
take your relationships to the next
level uh try out john delony's questions
for humans couples edition or i just did
a little book the other day called the
momentum theorem works for couples works
for people works for careers works for
everything if you're looking for a
career change to grow your income or pay
off debt faster you can check out ken
coleman's resume templates there's all
kinds of ways we can help you when you
finally say enough is enough
the 10 sale
whether it's paying off debt building
wealth improving your relationships or
your career not a bad return on
investment again that's up to 83 off the
10 sale at ramseysolutions.com
i don't know where else you can get a
best-selling hardback book for 10 bucks
inflation didn't hit us here at ramsey
dave we kept our prices actually
inflation did hit us but we didn't raise
our prices anyway it hit us just like
the costco we're not gonna make it hit
you that's it yeah
well we'll get around to it we get
around to raising our prices one of
these days open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
christina is in new york city hi
christina welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um so my question is i
own property i'm contributing to my
retirement
and i have about 150 000 saved in like a
growth money market account
so i'm just not really sure like should
i just keep that money in that account
and just keep you know putting into it
should i invest it in some way i just
want to make sure like i'm doing like
the responsible thing how soon are you
wanting to use that money maximizing
how soon are you wanting to use that
money is this a one to two year is this
five
years or more
you say again how soon will you need the
money
uh well i i don't i don't like need it
like for anything i'm just i'm just
saving okay you just wanted to grow are
you out of debt 100
yes no mortgage no i mean i don't want
to say i'm out of debt i mean i own my
house so no mortgages
no i have a mortgage
okay how much is your mortgage
um like 3 500 a month no baby the
balance
oh well i just sold my condo and just
bought a house with my fiance so the
balance right now that we always like
650.
okay
you bought a house with your fiance
yes
and when is the marriage taking place
uh next year
okay
all right you're in a very precarious
and dangerous situation until you're if
you're not going to get married soon you
guys need to get some written
documentation
immediately
on this house
okay
if something goes sideways horrible in
your all's lives this house is going to
be a major problem if it happens before
marriage
okay you can you tell you're talking to
a guy who's seen cancer before and i
know what cancer looks like
yeah
okay
so you didn't even think of all these
things bad things that could happen but
for 30 years i've been doing this with
people that have had all the bad things
happen
okay
so something bad happens in the
relationship you're suddenly a partner
with your former fiance
in a house
that needs some written partnership
documentation
and partnership documentation deals with
the d's death disability
drug use
default
divorce
which can't happen here but it could be
called uh i saw him on facebook with
another girl or something like i don't
know i don't think it's gonna happen to
you i doubt it's gonna happen to you but
you need all this written down kiddo i
don't want you being one of our
customers for the wrong reasons okay
because you just scared me to death when
you said that now
having said all of that does your fiance
have any money
um yeah he does
cash
uh in the bank yeah how much
um probably ten
okay so you're the rich one
okay you're the saver he's the spender
okay and what does he make a year
uh 130 000. great cool and what do you
make a year
the same good excellent so you got a 260
000 combined income
um when you do get it combined by
marriage uh
today let's see here
does he have debt other than this house
no
none
not a student loan not a car payment not
nothing
uh well he does have a car payment i
think but i mean i think it's going to
be peter what do you think debt is
it's got to be paid off in a year
okay
i actually give you any debt no do you
have a mortgage yes does your other
foundation have any debt no does he have
a car payment yes
i have a car payment oh you have a car
payment goodness gracious
is there any other non-debt that you
have that's debt
no that's it just the mortgage and the
car payments
okay what's the car loan balance
um
i'm lee i mean i just signed a lease so
okay i i would call the i would call the
lease company and ask what the early
buyout is lisa's basically financing a
car and i would write a check today
you're not gonna do any of this but i'm
gonna tell you what you should do okay
and i would pay off your car today he
should start working to get his paid off
as soon as he possibly can you said he
was on plan to do it inside of a year
okay that's number two number one
suggestions pay yourself number two
suggestions he needs to pay his off
don't pay off his car until you're
married
the faster you guys can actually get
married the faster you're gonna solve
all the financial and legal mumbo jumbo
that you're getting into because it's
very difficult for you to work together
and be protected against bad situations
until you're married
so the faster you're married i know it's
not romantic and it wasn't your plan but
the faster you're married the more you
solve the issues under new york law with
the house ownership
and with the uh
you know because you could reach over
today
and i would suggest this and george
would suggest this and throw the 150 at
the house and start reducing the house
because that's our next step is get your
house paid off once your cars are paid
off but i don't want you paying off a
house that you're in joint ownership
with a broke person on
okay
and right now you're a partner with a
broke person now that's a financial
analysis it's not saying your your
fiance is a deadbeat or something like
that but he has 10 grand you have 150
grand
you both make 130 okay you know if so
let me tell you what happened one time
this is not going to happen to you
but this is why i'm freaking out so
you'll understand i'm not just a weirdo
okay
i had a lady in the exact same situation
you're in the the fiance gets killed in
a car wreck now she owns the house with
his parents
yeah that was what i was told actually
happens like yeah that's exactly what
does happen unless there's a will
so there needs to be a will in place
today with the partnership agreement so
that you get the entire freaking house
if something happens he gets the entire
freaking house or something happens okay
and that's what that's why i'm freaking
out here i don't think that's gonna
happen what are the percentage chances
of that nothing probably but this is
what you've opened yourself up to by
engaging in what felt like the right
thing to do because your relationship is
strong okay and i'm not saying he's a
bad guy or you're a bad girl i'm not
saying any of that i'm just saying
you're just open to that and it scares
me for you
so i want you to protect yourself and
the sooner you get married the less soon
you have to do all that so if you run
down and get married this weekend and
then have the celebration in a year
then legally you're fine
and to worry about anymore if you did
that then i'm going to pay off both cars
immediately out of your 150 and throw
the rest at the house wouldn't you
absolutely but
we got to do some things in order here
and there's a lot of mortgage here and
the car payments and it makes me sick to
my stomach yeah but you got 260 000
income assuming you're married
that's cool i mean making a freaking
quarter of a million dollars even in new
york city that's a lot of money
so hey hang on we're going to put you
guys through financial peace university
as our wedding gift because i think the
wedding is pending
dave just sped up the process you think
i might have dialed it up i don't i
doubt it i doubt i had any impact at all
but it's fun to try this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage ray and
chris are with us hey guys how are you
hey good how are you doing better than i
deserve sir welcome it's good to have
you guys where do you live minneapolis
minnesota awesomeness very cool good to
have you visit thanks for being with us
it's great to be here and all the way
down into the deep south of nashville to
do a debt-free scream how much did you
pay off 143 616.69
i love it and how long did that take
about 18 months we
were scheduled to do it in 24 and we did
an 18. you jacked it up all right and
what was your range of income during
that 18 months you're about 170 to about
242. cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a regional sales manager in the
automation industry
and i'm a contract specialist for
electrical subcontractor cool cool so
how did your income jump
70 000 bucks in 18 months i'm a
salesperson so
i had a reason to make a sale yeah we
had we had really good income and then
it went down a little bit and then back
up this year way to go killing it good
for you guys so what kind of debt was
the hundred and forty four thousand it
was a little bit of everything i don't
think there's a debt we didn't like so
um we had lines of credit we had uh
bathtubs we had hvac
uh you had dead on your bathtub oh yeah
yeah soaker tub yep yep a soaker tub
yeah well that makes a difference very
important yeah
was that for you i'm guessing
yeah we just we just loved debt so that
was yeah whatever we want we just go get
it and we'll pay for it later cars
you're full on america yep previously we
paid off student loans for our kids
previously so yeah so what happened what
what was the wake-up call the change of
heart um part of it was um covid but the
the big thing that happened september
28th i got let go of my job first sales
job i've ever been let go of and they
decided they didn't need sales people
and her security gland went off
and so we decided we better do something
okay so she freaked out because you're
like we're we're going we're going to
broke here absolutely that's september
28th of 2020. it's only 20. yeah right
in the middle of kovid's stuff yep yep
so got us a little scared and uh why did
so really they were just covered scared
the company was and they freaked out and
dumped you in the street no they weren't
coping scared they just didn't think
they needed sales people anymore oh they
were stupid yeah well incredible
business model i can't say that on the
air i just did
yeah
wow i regularly call companies like that
stupid so i'm kind of used to it so you
went from loving debt to instantly
hating it going we got to get rid of
this asap yeah that's a big mindset
shift yeah and that's that's the biggest
part of our story is the mindset the
mindset shift is the
is the what we went through so we we did
that within a few weeks our daughter and
son-in-law asked if they could move in
to our house so they could get debt free
wow and so we started this journey and
we um
get to how did you get connected to
ramsey man that's a great great question
i don't know eight or ten years ago we
um we had heard about you in a class at
church it wasn't an fpu class we heard
about you looked you up and we decided
to gift fpu to our our son and
daughter-in-law when they got married
having never read it and didn't know
anything about it we just thought oh
this would be a great and that's many
years ago eight years ago eight years
ago yeah and so then a friend of mine
nathan um he uh
he said during covet i started getting
tired of listening to the news and
was kind of going through that you know
that kind of angry stage he goes oh you
should just listen to dave ramsey he's
he'll um he'll lift you up every day
and just give you something an
alternative to listen to so i started
binge listening to
every podcast when i traveled and um
that's just kind of what started me on
the journey so it got us going kind of
looking at you know that and the bigger
thing for us was
having to sit down and look back at our
what we had been spending yeah so that's
a big wake-up call too
you're like what yeah yeah that's what i
did when i looked at it i'm like you got
to be kidding me yeah unfortunately
coveted had built some of it in for us
so for the first six months before we
even started this we weren't going out
to eat and that was one of our biggest
spending areas there you go so we had
already kind of started taking all that
out and you didn't die and we did that
yeah we didn't die it was amazing so uh
did you go back to fpu then no you know
did you ever go through it never went
through the podcast i know i the podcast
and i started buying every book i could
buy so i i think i've read almost
everything uh that you've put out and oh
wow okay one of them one of them was
good was rachel's book uh
know yourself know your money yeah
that's helpful yep yeah because you guys
have been married a while yeah 36 years
all right all right we just celebrated
40. so we're in the same club yeah yeah
very cool good for you guys have you
guys ever been no go ahead go ahead in
your marriage have you been debt-free in
36 years i don't know there might have
been like three minutes or four minutes
yeah maybe credit card but i don't know
about car maybe briefly yeah
yep just for a moment and then you got
over it yeah because what i said before
is we we were raising homes that never
never talked about money and
we'd really never had anybody sit down
with us and talk us through this like
you do you know through your material so
we we started looking at it differently
and that's what kind of changed us
because we had to get to a point about
you know nine months into the journey my
daughter and son-in-law challenged us to
a year-long debt debt reduction ooh um
contest
game on family
don't compete with the sales guy yeah
that's right we did win yeah we did win
and we had already paid off about 80 000
and so this that was the rest of our
debt we decided to be fair we should
probably put our mortgage into the into
the contest so we could be fair with our
kids
and uh both of our kids we all this is
mortgage and everything this is
mortgages
you are weird people yes i knew it all
right where'd it go what's the
houseworth
um i don't know what we think it's about
350 because what we're thinking how much
do you have saved in retirement um well
the last time i looked in december
before
2022 started we were probably about
almost 800 000. okay so at that point
you if you're still there you would beat
over a million net worth yep so you
became baby steps millionaires in the
process absolutely yeah or you will be
again shortly if not yeah well done you
guys very cool and we had never looked
at it that way we had you know i'd never
really sat down and looked at our 401k
and and kind of added those things up
but as we started looking at it we're
you know
baby steps millionaires yeah just way to
go man you did everything right very
well done well know yourself know your
money is really important rachel's
material
on this collection like you said earlier
the family you come from it tends to the
way your family
of origin handled money influences the
way you handle money and your spouse
doesn't always understand that they're
like where did you get that you weirdo
well that's why we always did it at my
house you know so you gotta you gotta
get through that stuff and that really
helps to get on the same page doesn't it
yep absolutely
so what's the most important thing if
somebody wants to get out of debt that
they need to do
i would say quit spending we just
stopped we bought food that we needed
and paid heat and
our house payment but other than that we
just stopped spending and it felt like
we had a raise at the end of the month
yeah big time yeah i think for me it was
really the
the change of heart is as far as debt
goes so we like i said when we started
that contest my son-in-law said hey are
you turning off your 401k are you
getting down to a thousand dollars in
your savings account and when those two
things happen the hardest things we did
were those two things but when we did
them it changed our mindset about money
it just totally changed we got you know
intense we got scared we got all those
things you feel when you when you do
those things and that's kind of what
spurred us the last in fact we thought
it would take a year and it took the
last part only took nine months to to
get done so your son-in-law gives you
the hacks on how to win the contest and
you beat him yeah that doesn't seem fair
yeah yeah he's he he's kind of a quiet
guy but um when when he he got on all
these ramsey facebook yeah um groups and
he started you know it's almost 400 000
people in that career yeah that's crazy
yeah and he was uh he was coming up with
stuff he printed off our our debt-free
uh journey
thing for us so we could do that and all
right so awesome we're proud of you guys
you guys are amazing i've enjoyed
talking to you i'm so proud of you give
you a great picture on it can be done
and it should be done and here's what
you got to do yep very very well done we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you since you are one my latest
number one best seller and uh we'll give
you a one year uh subscription
membership to financial peace university
you've never been through it you ought
to go through it yeah you don't
technically need everything in there
anymore but you'll probably learn
something and then you'll want to give
it away to somebody else probably so
good stuff and we've got a copy of total
money makeover for you to give away to
somebody and get them moving you've got
these books a lot of them probably so
you can give them away good stuff ray
and chris from minneapolis 144 000 paid
off in 18 months making 170 to 242 count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're dead free
house and everything
baby steps millionaires
all in 18 months that's how it works
right there baby they're not messing
around whoa
whoa
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money mackenzie
is with us
mackenzie is in portland oregon hi
mackenzie how are you
hi i'm good thank you
so my question is my husband is a
dentist and he gets paid through his
pllc
that he was advised to set up
he recently started with the new company
and has the opportunity
to either continue getting
keeping like his pllc or switching to
w-2 and we've been advised that
on both w-2
is a better option for him and then
obviously the pllc is a better option
for him if you were wondering what your
thoughts were
[Applause]
well when you're self-employed on 1099
you have the opportunity to pay both
sides of fica
they call that self-employment tax
because uh washington dc is so friendly
to small business people
uh we're pro-business no you're not you
crush small business people because uh
when you're a small business person on
1099 or just a small business person you
get to pay both sides of fica so you got
15.3 there
plus your tax rate if you're on w-2 you
have seven half of that um you know 765
plus your tax rate
is the tax implications now
as a w-2 there's no write-offs
if you have business expenses
associated with this action you can
deduct those
um does he have business expenses
no with this new company he really has
very minimal they pay
like his malpractice and his um
continuing education his ce courses
either way um
yeah yeah they would pay either way even
if he stays with the plc
okay the only other thing i can think is
is the plc might actually have
value as a practice
if he has the income going through it
it's a dental practice he has a dental
practice he's self-employed under the
plc which is a uh basically a
corporation that set up folks for
listening for medical
okay it's a a small business corporation
for medical
um sometimes lawyers will use it as well
it's the only time i ever see it those
law firms and medical doc medical
practices i don't see it anywhere else
um
so you see what i'm saying if he has
dollars going through that
company then that company starts to have
value it's not really got any values
apart from him being attached to it
because he's the only horse in the race
only horse creating the value
but um but you might begin to lay a
track record of that
i don't know that he's
i don't know that he can do 10.99 here
because a lot of companies uh try to put
people on 10.99
because it's less expensive for them on
the fica
and they're really not 1099 eligible
when a company furnishes you everything
the clients the location
they furni they do all the marketing
they cover all the overhead they're
covering his insurance
they're covering everything he's an
employee at that point
and i if it walks like a duck and talks
like a duck it's a duck under tax law
and so i i you know i don't i'm not i'm
not positive because i'm not a tax
expert but there's some guidelines on
what is and isn't a 1099.
it's going to vary state by state as
well and so i would look at what the no
1099 doesn't vary well the other the
other rules there so i'm wondering for
the w-2 side
or is there any harm in just switching
to the w-2 what are we gaining by going
with the 1099
the only thing i can think of here is is
that you're just building the value of
the practice potentially but not much
who who recommended that mckenzie
you said they recommended
our tax accountant okay said double
youtube
yeah i guess some reason for the pllc is
if anything comes back
at
him
it protects
i know and so that i guess yeah i don't
know
yeah
malpractice should cover that and he's
an employee at that point employees
don't get sued the employer gets sued if
he screws up somebody's mouth
okay that's true you know so the pllc
has just seemed to be so expensive
too
and like all these different well yeah
you're going to have some associated
things that we have to do
i don't know what oregon's tax is on
that in tennessee we don't have one
llc's you don't get taxes all passed
through on the federal level there's no
tax on it it's all passed through but i
don't know whether oregon has a separate
thing if they're taxing you on it then
that settles it for sure
and you've got to file a tax return on
the stupid thing
you know and you have to pay your
corporate
registration fees every year to keep it
open
and all of that would you dissolve it if
he went to w2
yes i probably would yeah i think i'm
gonna i think i'm going with your tax
accountant
because number one your tax account i'm
assuming your tax accountant knows
oregon law as well
yeah yeah
i i i think
mathematically i'm
positive you're going to come out ahead
with w-2 and i'm having trouble finding
any good reason to keep the other thing
in place so i'm going with your text one
thing is that
our kids are involved in
doing things and so they say that they
can be paid
that way and that oh whoop
like
yeah just just put just go make some
money don't worry about that
i mean you can take care of your kids
later that's the whole thing of you can
pay your kids through your business and
all that but your kid actually has to be
providing market value work
i mean so you can't have a
three-year-old that's making 8 000 a
year
um you'll get audited and lose the audit
and people do that crap but i've seen
the tick tock videos it's not pretty
dave yeah it's just well nothing on tick
tock is pretty george why are you even
on there
and just so wrong myself up you know it
riles me up that you're on it yeah the
uh uh
so yeah the yeah i'm with you i'm with
your tax account let's do it
let's do it
that that's simple um well i'm going
ahead you can always come back later if
something changes in your world and you
want to form another one that kind of
thing i'd give it a year and keep track
of all the numbers and see how it shakes
down with the w2 yeah now here's the
thing sometimes and this is this i'm
still not sure is the case here i
you're not eligible to be a 1099 people
some people just declare you know it's
like uh michael scott on uh i declare
bankruptcy i declare bankruptcy i
declare you a 1099. you can't do the irs
very specific and who can
there's like 12 guidelines that have to
be met i can't remember but a couple of
them are you can't get all your if you
have one customer you have one set of
the and all your marketing your location
your supplies
your insurance
everything is supplied to you you're not
10.99 by definition you don't qualify
anymore because you are you're an
employee 1099 means you are
self-employed
that's what it means so like a real
estate agent is an example of someone
who is a 1099 but does work out of one
office but they supply they create all
their own leads they have all their own
marketing or the vast majority of it and
they do they buy their own office
supplies they pay gas for their car they
buy their own insurance they pay their
own mls fees they're in business for
themselves and contracts
if you're you know working for uber or
one of those you know side hustlers
independent contractor for sure for sure
you're providing your own car you're
providing all this other crap involved
but this thing where you know you go to
work at a place
and everything is you're acting and
looking and walking and talking like an
employee by definition your employee and
but sometimes these small particularly
small businesses will violate this they
will just say uh we don't want to pay
that fica stuff that extra half of that
and so we're just going to make you a
10.99 and you is on your own and you're
self-employed you don't get to do that
that's you need to look up the irs
guidelines i'm not an expert on it but i
have seen people audited in the small
business world and get screwed over with
this stuff well if you're self-employed
you better be working with a great tax
pro anyways there's a lot of things that
you know you're not thinking about when
it comes to deductions and you know
being strategic with making sure you're
making the most of that money and don't
pay your kids more than you could hire
another kid
to do the job for it won't survive an
audit
and so i mean we had our kids were
employed with us but we only paid them
you know a market rate for that job
and they weren't doing much they didn't
get paid much they were kids
so that's how this works you don't send
them the salt mines yeah that that's
that sounds like something you hear at
some seminar somewhere or something that
you get ripped off well hack a wealth
hack oh god shoot me
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today and
joining us in studio one of our great
friends dr meg meeker she is the author
of the book strong father strong
daughters if you all haven't heard the
story
a while back i was in a group of men
started as a bible study and
deteriorated into a book club
and uh
we were reading through different books
and one of the guys in there brings this
book in there called strong father
strong daughters now at this point my
daughters were already grown
i read this book and it is such a
powerful
statement on the importance of dads
in their daughter's lives and time and
time and time again so i immediately uh
once i read it i just got blown away and
i reached out and i didn't know that meg
and i were actually brother and sister
we found out later that we're way too
much alike
and uh you know that was that i don't
know what year did that book come out a
long time ago um i'm thinking 0406 yeah
so we've been we go we've been friends
almost 20 years
and uh so meg has done speaking with us
on smart conference uh she's been on
this show multiple times speaking on
the subject of parenting in general
makes a pediatrician in traverse city up
in michigan and has been by practice but
also has become a best-selling author
many many best-selling books
strong father's strong daughters
continues to be
an explosive subject and now has been
made into a movie congratulations
i haven't had a movie made yet that's a
big deal you'll get that i'm jealous so
i beat you at one thing
no competition none whatsoever not it's
thrilling you know i had nothing to do
with it of course it's a god thing but
um
they a number of years ago pureflix
bought the rights from the publisher and
i thought oh yeah yeah and then all
sudden a year ago they said going to
come out as a movie and i said oh yeah
yeah and then august 1st it came out and
it's really good wow and it's really
good see that's the important thing i
mean they didn't mess it up well you
know i was nervous i bet yeah because my
name's all over it yeah and
your best known title is on it exactly
um but but i was i was thrilled when i
actually saw it because it's cute it it
conveys the message of my book there
pretty well
and and it shows my book in there and
it's just it's a it's a real shot in the
arm for dads and you know me i am so pro
dad my mission in life is to encourage
fathers because they get zero
and um so i think the movie accomplishes
that and i'm thrilled yeah did you get
to be an extra in it did they let you i
wouldn't even if they did that's not my
thing you could have at least had a
cameo just done a walk that would have
been amazing
well did you get a say in the movie meg
of how it portrays so they showed me the
first manuscript and
i said i don't know could you make some
changes and they did and then i signed
off on the final one but i couldn't i
couldn't to choose the actors or anybody
but wow yeah you weren't in charge of
casting how do you how do they watch it
pure flicks how do they watch it go to
pureflix.com and they can watch the
trailer which is cute and then the whole
movie and i've really encouraged people
to watch it it's light it's not heavy
you know and now everybody hears so much
bad news it's a sit sit-down feel-good
movie and it encourages dads so if you
if they know a dad needs a little
encouragement
in a culture who's completely devalued
fatherhood
i don't think of anything more evil than
a dad out there in the culture right now
exactly exactly and i'm not only not
encouraged but discouraged discouraged
and that's why i do what i do and i will
do it till i
fall over um because dad's
getting dads engaged in the family is i
think the most important thing we can do
in our culture it would solve so many
problems so financial social
psychological
you know in in families and their kids
lives and i'm just so passionate about
that so
you got questions on parenting we've got
dr meg for another segment you can jump
in right now triple eight eight two five
five
two two five any question on parenting's
open triple eight eight two five five
two two five she's our resident
parenting expert although she's not
resident and uh we're just glad she's
with us today so triple eight eight two
five five two two five austin's gonna
open up a couple lines and make sure
that you guys can get through with those
because we've only got her for one more
segment to do that so you think they
represent the book well i do
i you know me
i'm a little intense
i i don't know anybody like that
this is why you're kindred
a spirits bit a little bit we have some
of the best arguments on the planet and
i always win and you always watch i
always win that's hard don't no it's
easy it's impossible to do that yeah so
uh i'll let you win this argument for
today the uh whatever it is but um what
i was gonna say is i would have made the
book a little more serious a little more
the movie the movie a little more
serious a little more intense but it
probably wouldn't have sold if if i did
it so they they lightened it up but they
did they they you know communicated it's
got a good story arc very good story
yeah that's good that's good okay so for
the ones that have never heard of the
you or this discussion before we're
acting like everybody knows what we're
talking about um
the data that is in the book strong
father strong daughters is
irrefutable
on the evidence of
girls ladies end up
this this this and this and this more
often if dad is involved or that's not
involved rattle off some of that
girls are
more likely to graduate from high school
more likely to graduate from college
less likely to have depression and
anxiety
more likely to be successful in life you
know you name it um girls are better off
almost twice as good they do twice as
well in life unwanted pregnancies less
oh stds or less stds are like and this
is um very this is data this is not your
no no no no no it's times of research
well and that's why you know when people
come out in the public and they say oh
kids don't need a dad well look at the
research how can you just say that it's
all wrong so as a physician you know
everything i write has to be medically
backed with solid medical evidence and
that's exactly what i do in the book i
don't just come up with ideas and sort
of tell anecdotal stories or make things
up it sounds good i really write
things based on medical research
and you know it's really just gotten um
more and more and more problems with
kids you see the explosion of depression
anxiety right now in kids you know that
was much worse today than it was 10 or
15 years ago so
i really believe that the message in my
book is more important today than it was
10 or 15 years ago yeah so moms are
important too very important but they
have a very different role and we're not
willing to say that in our culture we
don't we're not willing to say you know
boys a boy and a girl's girl
but
but you know that a mother is a mother
and a dad's a dad's dad's bring
something very different to the family
than mothers do you know mothers are the
the comfortable um
cozy warm emotionally connected and dads
of the authority and dads have an
authority in a daughter's eyes that
mothers don't nobody wants to say that
but it's true in the daughter's eye yeah
and the ability to speak life exactly
from that authority is very very
important change your life yeah very
cool dr meg meeker the book of strong
father strong daughters is now a movie
on pure flicks back with your calls and
questions for her and george's as well
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today dr meg meeker joining us
our good friend and author of the book
strong fathers
strong daughters if you want to talk to
dr mick call us at triple eight eight
two five
five
5225
james is on the line in mobile alabama
with a question for dr meg meeker hey
james what's up
hey hey nothing too much how you doing
great how can we help
hey i have a question for the doc
uh adopted a newborn at three days old
should i tell her she's adopted if so
when
yes you you need to tell her she's
adopted because she will find out and if
she finds out when she's 20 or 25 she's
going to be very angry with you because
she'll feel like her life was a lie
i would tell her fairly early on when
she can understand three or four years
of age and what you say is you were so
special that mommy and daddy picked you
out and we brought you home because we
loved you
um and then chosen you're chosen you're
chosen we're all adopted and yes be very
forthright
answer questions don't hammer her over
the head with it but yeah yeah you'll
have a much better relationship if you
are honest with her i mean she's 15 now
and she's going to be 16. so hamlet's
the same way
yes does she know she's adopted now and
she's no she don't know what i'm saying
she don't have any idea right now oh and
she's 15.
yeah so yeah would i have it in the
difference
uh i waited too late no no no no no it's
never too late but you but you do you
you go and you say something like this
you know honey i probably should have
told you when you're earlier i didn't
know what to do
never had an adopted child but i need to
tell you you were adopted
and you know and this is what happened
and here's how you were chosen she's
going to be mad because you've sort of
in her mind lied to her all these years
but that's where you ask her to forgive
you for not knowing what to do and not
having told her sooner but she'll she'll
be okay with that i don't i have limited
experience because i've had two
daughters
uh but every 15 year old daughter i've
had was a drama queen so you expect some
extra drama oh yeah because of her age
yelling and crying and screaming it's
okay it's okay let her do it there's
gonna there's not gonna be easy but
nothing's easy when you have a 15 year
old daughter so that's there's just
everything that goes okay and if you
want to meet our parents do i try to
find them or
how would i handle that i would say why
don't we why don't we wait a while um
it's your choice you sure can
meet your your parents but i think it's
good to wait till you're 18 a little bit
older
and um do that if she's really insistent
on meeting her parents yet and i but but
it was close adoption i don't think you
can until the child's 18.
it's my understanding yeah and okay but
yeah i i i all i'm doing is just being
dad here i don't know what i'm talking
about but uh just i i would expect
that uh an initial blow up but don't
if you don't make a bigger deal out of
this she's less likely to exactly if
this is just a matter-of-fact low-key
thing
we loved you so much we picked you out
we chose you
um i kind of think i probably should
have told you earlier but i didn't know
what to do i've never been this
situation before it's a new thing for me
so i'm sorry for the emotions that
you're going to feel for this but i want
to let you know we picked you out you're
chosen you're you you didn't just um the
stork didn't choose you and so uh we did
so you're special in that regard and i
hope you see it that way honey and and i
know you're going to go through a series
of emotions about this and i'm going to
be there with you because i'm still your
dad right
okay one last question since school just
started to wait till holiday or
let her get adjusted to this beginning
of the new school year or just go ahead
and do it now i'd let her get adjusted
what what what grade is she
well she's doing the dual enrollment so
she's going to college in high school at
the same time so yeah she got a lot on
her plate i'd wait till her life kind of
settles into a new rhythm you don't want
to have too many changes at once i mean
you've waited this long what's waiting a
few more months yeah hey let me tell you
something dude
okay she's going to be okay
you know i know
she's got a great dad
the questions you've asked tell us how
plugged into her you already are yeah
she's got a great dad she's gonna be
okay she is gonna be okay and you are a
great dad you know just calling in and
asking and being concerned that's the
most important thing yeah i mean i i
honestly wouldn't have thought of that
question
like i mean what to wait till things
calm down i'm just like well yeah you
should've done i mean you know
but i mean he's actually has a feeling
they're selling a one-year-old
listen son what happened
well i mean
and you know
now it's grand baby so we just hand them
back if they're crying okay you go go
see go see your mom you're messed up
here i can't help you with this
you're a great dad yeah i've watched
your parents you're a great dad yeah i'm
a better granddad though
all men are oh man so is my husband
yeah my daughter's like who are you
what did you do with my father exactly
yeah we get 20 years experience then you
become uh you get it you get it figure
it out so let's go back to what we're
talking about before the break number
one you've got uh the master class now
on strong father's strong daughters
because the book strong fathers have
been a bestseller like we said for over
a decade almost two decades and um
but a lot of the things you get with
that book same things i get with my
books okay now what do i i get it but
what do i do what do i do exactly it's
like financial piece the book was here's
what to do or here here's the stuff and
then everybody's like well what do i do
so i wrote totally makeover and then
total money makeovers the what to do
book and it took off and it's the
biggest seller i've ever had yeah
because you need step-by-step
instructions particularly that's what
you do with them that's what i do with a
master class strong father-strong
daughter's master class and it's me
going through every chapter of the book
and his videos i summarize the chapter
and then i say here's what you do from
this chapter and then chapter two and
then i have downloadable one page help
so it's very short it's quick it's easy
and i just found so many men asked for
it they read the book and they go this
is great but
you know literally tell me what i need
instructions
me i need instructions yeah but tell me
what to do but when it comes to a man
you know dad's trying to enter
daughter's world they're like i just
don't know and i mean people say you
know what do i do with my daughter and
i'll go into this philosophical no what
do i do with her on saturday because i
have her saturday i don't know what to
do
you know
so anyway and this is it it's a
step-by-step instruction of here's how
you work out what i talked about in my
strong five strong daughters book and
people from the ramsey listeners get um
20
off if they use your uh name code ramsay
meekerparenting.com i've become a code
code ramsey it's all you're good for
dave it's a good discount
i'm there for you man well we're we're
excited about it meg that's awesome
there's a lot of dads out there who are
going what the crap do i do i hope so
this is really really good stuff all
right uh in just a few moments that we
got left i'm i'm thinking
that i remember us talking on the air
one time and it was really poignant
uh
moms seem to uh naturally understand the
power of physical touch
and i remember i was doing youth work
one time and i was reading a book on
youth work and it said when you have
teenage daughters if dads if you don't
give them hugs someone else will that's
right that's right you know when fathers
will say well my daughter doesn't like
me she doesn't want to hug me she pulls
back of course she does because she's
very uncomfortable about who she is it's
not about you
the time when a daughter pulls back you
need to move in you need to touch her
you need to hug her you need to show her
affection she wants it she needs it and
absolutely right if you give it to her
she's not going to go looking for it and
she will look for somebody to give her
affection the way you did if you are
respectful and loving and kind
guess what kind of boyfriend she's going
to choose you know the first time she
she uh is dating a guy and he's not like
dad
out he goes
and dads don't realize that you're the
standard in our minds for how we're to
be treated so if you are respectfully uh
showing affection and love to your
daughter
she will expect nothing less when she
dates or goes to marry somebody yeah it
helps her pick well does
yeah and how you treat your wife men
absolutely they're watching morris
caught and taught yep to quote rachel
cruz there we go good stuff
dr mcmaker appreciate your friendship
appreciate the work you do in this
nation the book is strong fathers strong
daughters it's now a movie on pureflix
and the master class is at
meekerparenting.com
use the code ramsey for 30 off thanks
for hanging out thank you dave
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about life and money parents
there's a lot you can't control you
can't control inflation you can't
control the economy sure as crap can't
control washington but you can control
how you teach your teens to face this
stuff
and sooner or later they're gonna face
it and the earlier they learn the better
the best thing you can teach your teen
this year is how to handle their money
the right way things like how to budget
how to save how to spend wisely how to
be outrageously generous foundations in
personal finance is our high school
curriculum that is also now a homeschool
curriculum
it's in 48 percent of america's high
schools it'll give your teens the tools
they need to win with money to pay cash
for college
stay out of debt build wealth be
generous it's not just another
homeschool curriculum it's completely
changing how teens think about money and
it can change how your teen thinks too
this year you can give your teens the
money skills they'll need now and for
the rest of their lives foundations and
personal finance to learn more go to
ramseysolutions.com
homeschool george we're seeing a number
of people now on the debt-free stage
doing their debt-free scream that says
you know dave back in high school
i went through foundations and personal
finance does that make you feel old
george that was not the point okay but
the impact is amazing and i get
instagram messages of people you know
teens going i just finished the
curriculum thank you guys so much it's
going to set me up for success i'm going
to go to school debt free i've got my
emergency fund and i'm going these kids
are doing better than most adult
americans it's amazing yeah which is a
fairly low bar but they are the
fair point
but i'd love to see the impact on this
next generation check it out folks
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is our number here lines are
available charles is with us in orlando
hi charles welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking me on this
morning this afternoon sure question is
regarding my parents my parents back in
the 70s virtues to home with my uncle so
three of them were sole survivorship
since then my my dad passed in 2010 my
uncle just passed in 2021 and now my mom
has rights of survivorship over this
house the problem is uh my cousins live
in the house and they're just
giving my mom a hard time about moving
out
uh
and so
i think this is more like a moral
question for my part should
should because the bible says not to
you know not to argue with your within
your families and and to ar you know to
agree quickly with your enemies things
like that so my question i have an
influence over my mom
should my mom
pursue the eviction because she just
wants to sell the house
she wants to you know give you know
just
just
it's just hard yeah
well you're sweet people you're kind
people and um
when the bible talks about agreeing
quickly or
uh going along there's another scripture
that says as so
so far as you are able
to
work along with people i mean there's a
whole there's a
less parrot talks about the verse with
the most qualifiers of anything in the
bible but
you know as much as you are able and in
this case you may not be able because
um
you know you can't get along with
someone who refuses to
get along
and so the bible does not require that
we are doormats it just requires that
we're kind when we're strong
there's a difference and so some
strength is needed here how old is your
mom
she's 83
okay
so
what you have here is you have cousins
that are taking advantage of a sweet old
lady
yeah and so your mom doesn't need to
handle this you do
with your mom's with your mom's
permission it's not fair to her at 82
years old at the deal with these
characters
and these people are characters they are
not entitled to this house are they
no you know it was a contract my uncle
did with my mom yeah my dad you know you
couldn't have bought that house without
my mom's and my dad's
assistant and it was left and it was
left with survivor intentionally so your
mother is 100 owner of the house
yeah yeah so regardless of how we got
here boys and girls
mom owns this house a hundred percent
yeah and she has and that does not that
there is no obligation
anywhere written or unwritten said or
unsaid that allows you guys to get to
live here for free
all right
so you don't know yeah so you don't so
here's what we're going to do
okay
you guys are going to start paying rent
and you're going to maintain the
property
or you need to make arrangements to live
somewhere else it's up to you
and we'll give you a little time to get
all that done
but um this is ending
yeah and i you know how much time do you
need i mean let's give them three months
i don't care it's been years
yeah it's been eight months already
since your uncle died
it's been over 18 months since my uncle
died it's been eight months since we
told him so my mom said okay we're
selling the house and getting
notifications they were paying rent for
almost the whole year last year oh okay
okay i got a different story i'm sorry
no no no i i didn't explain it correctly
sorry but your mom wants to sell
regardless she doesn't want even if they
paid rent yeah she wants to sell this
house and be done with it okay so they
just need to move yes
okay so here's the deal um you know what
i would do is just jump on the phone
with them um
or send them a text if you want and say
listen i've been talking to mom about
this here's what mom says we're gonna do
and i'm giving you just as a cousin as
family um
you know uh what what is this this is
august 15th okay so here's what's going
to happen all right you are going to be
out of the house by september the 15th
30 days from today
if you are not out of the house and it's
not in good condition
when you leave
then we're going to have our attorney
evict you
we don't want to do that
please don't make us do that
let's just conduct this business and
let's conduct our affairs with class
and if we can help you in some way we
will let us know how we can help but uh
september the 15th the house needs to be
empty and clean
and if it is neither
we're going to have to take other
actions and i'm not going to
negotiate or argue with you about this
this is a statement of what is going to
happen if you are not gone by september
the 15th the next letter you get will be
from our attorney
so please don't make us go to that
expense and please don't let this go
into the courts it's silly to do that
yeah
and just be kind and firm and this is
what we're this is it's just very
matter-of-fact low-key no drama don't
get into the argument of who shot john
and 14 years ago somebody said the
bedroom was supposed to be pink or
whatever the crap family stuff brings up
right i don't know yes yes sir because
they do they want to go back they want
to circle back around chase their tail
again right yes sir yeah
so just don't feed into the drama so
what do you think the probability is
that when you call them to say september
15th to date and i'm gonna follow that
up with an email or a letter or whatever
you want so you'll have it in writing uh
what do you think the probability is
they're gone for you have to evict them
zero that's what i think
because i think they're entitled little
jerks
and i think they have they think they
have a right to something that they
don't have a right to they're ignorant
and so i'm afraid they're about to learn
a lesson
so
go ahead as soon as you make the phone
call because i'm in agreement with you i
think this is what's going to happen go
ahead and find a lawyer
and get the gun loaded so to speak
to where it doesn't take 30 more days
screwing around
right go ahead and go ahead and start
you know get everything moving to where
on september the 15th the thing's
already in motion
yes sir and whatever whatever notice in
the house in florida
those houses uh it's a it's up northeast
or northeast what state
uh new york state oh okay
yeah uh you probably got some different
laws there man
so you may have to give me the lawyer
may have to give them a formal 30-day
notice after this it may take you until
after christmas to get them out
right in some states it can be 30 days
but i doubt it in new york state i
suspect you probably got a a process
there that's gonna
make you gag but it's okay just still
just walk through and here's the thing
set the timeline in place and then push
every button on the timeline don't let
the can get kicked by anybody
kick don't know can kicking everybody's
going to go exactly where they have to
go and uh because these kiddos ain't
leaving unless they unless you make them
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 16 3
commit your actions to the lord and your
plans will succeed
thomas jefferson said i find that the
harder i work the more luck i seem to
have
now as einstein said hard
hard work always comes dressed in
overalls
or when luck always comes dressed in my
overalls that's what it was yeah luck
always comes dressed in overalls
einstein and jefferson and proverbs all
saying similar things here there you go
that's how it works
all right bailey's with us in green bay
bailey how are you
good how are you better than we deserve
what's up
great thanks for taking my call i have i
think a common question but maybe it's a
little different i'm moving jobs to a
different company and i'm currently
vested at my company
and as i move i'm wondering if i should
take my money with me or leave it with
my company
and if i take it with me i don't get to
keep the employer portion i only get to
keep the portion i have put in so that
would
move me about thirty thousand dollars
but if i leave the money there i can
take out the entire portion once i
retire
so what should i do it's a pension plan
it is yeah okay
so when you die a pension plan
evaporates
right it's worth zero
i think so i know so
and uh a 401 k or an ira or roth ira in
mutual funds
100 survives
you again goes to your heirs are you
married
yes okay
and uh if you had kids that kind of
stuff all right now
uh
so how much is how much is the pension
plan that will how much will it send to
you after they take out the thirty
thousand bucks
about thirty thousand
oh so it's a hundred percent you're
losing home or fifty percent you're
listening wow
okay
how old are you
29 okay so if you invest 30 000
in a roth ira in good mutual funds or
just an ira and good mutual funds with
it roll over to your 401k which you can
do here and you should do
um if you do that
uh the 30 000 will grow to a lot of
money by the time you get to retirement
agreed
i agree it will double about every seven
years
so if you're
29 and we went out uh three times a
double would be 30 to 60 to 120 to 240
um 21 years from today
and uh so you would be 50.
okay
uh as
in the pension it's going to grow at an
average of about seven percent which
means it's going to double about every
10 years
and so it will have gone during that
same period of time it will have gone
from 30 to 120.
so the answer is you're my you will have
a lot more money if you live past 50
in life
and in death
because the pension doesn't pay much
it's paying about seven percent
and the mutual funds are averaging
between uh 11 and 12 over the last uh 80
years
okay
and then so if i do take that money out
is it right that i need to pay the taxes
you're not gonna take it out you're not
gonna take it out you're gonna roll it
to a an ira
in good mutual funds and there's zero
taxes
okay
so go to rent it doesn't count as my
taxable income no
not if it's a direct rollover and
there's no penalties the direct rollover
so what you're going to do is go to
ramseysolutions.com click on smart
vester
and get a smart investor pro to help you
an investment broker that we recommend
okay and get somebody to help you and
then you'll fill out all the paperwork
to buy the mutual fund in an ira that
paperwork goes directly to your old
pension you'll need that information
they send the money directly into your
new uh into your new ira and that direct
transfer keeps it from ever having come
to you personally and then there is no
withholding and there is no taxes
okay
you're going to lose the 30 000 match
but you're going to make it up over the
next uh 20 years
by more than double
and um
and to survive sir now you'll break even
in 20 years
everything after 20 years if you live
longer than 50 years old you're going to
have more money at death
and more money at life
but until then you want to you won't
break even
because we're taking the 30 000 out
because she's actually got 60 in the
pension if she stays 30 is all we're
working with so i did the math wrong the
first time through so we're looking long
term here at the perks of this it takes
it takes it two decades it takes 21
years with the math i'm doing to do this
uh because her 60 will double
twice
and become 240 okay and then it'll be
120 then 240. it'll double twice but her
30 will double four times three times
and then that'll still be there and 30
years from now she'll be real thankful
she did that anything after 21 years
she'll be glad um or if she does pass
away at least she'll have some there'll
be something left versus it dying with
her
otherwise it'll be worth zero because it
at death is worth zero
and uh so that that's the difference so
usually you know most of these cases
that we run out we find you have more in
life and more in depth both by taking
your pension when you leave always take
your 401k with you when you leave
always roll it with a direct transfer
rollover like we just described because
you've got more options out there and
you've got more control and you'll end
up making more money even if your 401k
at your old place was strong you still
don't have to go back through the old hr
you have to go through all that crap to
get to your money it's just moving over
here into an ira and you buy the exact
same mutual funds even if you wanted to
um that were in your old 401k so always
take your 401k and almost always take
your pension yeah in this situation she
had 100 percent match it sounded like
yeah
that's the biggest penalty i've heard in
a long time for leaving with the pension
yeah
none of it yeah it's strange yeah well
she's not vested yet um so um
or no she was vested in her portion but
not in the company match portion
matthew is in uh boise hi matthew right
quick what's your question for a run out
of time
yeah for sure uh i'm
have a a small a small farm which we
have a mortgage on and we have about 60
000 of debt um separate to that um and
with my wife and i was like deciding
whether and we're really taught whether
to like um just continue paying
everything off and say and stay in the
um farm or whether to
sell it and from the equity have enough
to
pay off all that debt um pay off the
mortgage and be able to buy uh yeah what
what's your household income
um at the moment it's my income which is
about 80 000 and my wife has a business
which is debt free but she's been
investing all the money back in the
business so she hasn't been pulling an
income at this point in time
okay
um
you like the farm though don't you
yeah it's like it's a really like a
love-hate relationship but like some
days some days it's overwhelming
it depends on if i'm not tired that day
from working on the dadgum thing yeah i
don't blame you i get that i have a
love-hate relationship with some other
stuff i own
um
yeah i'm i'm gonna work my way through
it it's only 60 000 bucks
because i think you really like the farm
yeah
and i i think your heart would be broken
if you sold it now if you told me it was
six hundred thousand i'd probably be
dumping it because i think you couldn't
afford it
even if you liked it yeah because
yeah we have the debt of six thousand
our mortgage is actually about um 327
yeah on it yeah yeah but a 327 mortgage
if you live somewhere else would be
there too
yeah yeah because at the moment i am
yeah if we sold it we'd be around we've
got to sell it for around about a
million to 1.1 you sell it if you want
to dude uh but i think you like it i
heard that i don't think he has to sell
it to pay off the debt that's i'm not
seeing the numbers here going oh my gosh
you sell it today this is a nightmare he
can pay off this debt he's just wanting
to speed up the process and i think we
can do this how fast 60 making 80. uh i
give it two two and a half years max if
the income doesn't go up two years
thirty thousand a year and his wife's
income is going to kick in the business
gotta start making some money at some
point if she needs to get a job
so yeah two years two years thirty
thousand a year out of eighty 000 you're
done get this thing done roll up your
sleeves stay out of the restaurants quit
traveling no vacations we're paying off
the deal and keeping the farm yeah it's
like a hallmark movie we're going to
save the farm dave it's a hallmark movie
i feel like every hallmark movie is
about saving a farm i don't know is it
really yeah see the booth is the
difference is the booth and you have
actually seen hallmark movies and i
don't know i'm surprised sharon hasn't
made you watch one uh i have a good wife
so there you go
that puts the sour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you